une stratégie de vaccination souvent
qualifiée de satisfaisante mais une
hausse des cas qui n'en finit pas si
aujourd'hui la situation vécue par
israël qui a dû prolonger son
confinement jusqu'au 5 février
même s'il a été l'un des premiers pays à
vacciner massivement israël enregistre
ces derniers temps en plus de huit mille
nouveaux cas par jour mais autorité mise
plus que jamais sur cette campagne de
vaccination pour sortir de la crise
mi-août
nous sommes en pleine course entre notre
grande campagne de vaccination retour à
la vie et les variants ducobu de 19
cette campagne est la clé de notre plan
de sortie de crise vous me pour le
podium a recours aux mains déjà 5
millions de doses ont été administrées
dans le pays
moins de 2 millions d'israéliens ont
reçu la deuxième dose et les os de
contamination remettent en cause
l'efficacité du vaccin
en israël les infections monte en flèche
notamment chez les ultra-orthodoxes
décontamination qui proviendraient
majoritairement du variant britannique
dans ce cadre là le premier ministre
s'est fixé un objectif minimum
aujourd'hui j'ai fixé un objectif
national qui est la base de notre sortie
de crise vacciner au moins 90% de la
population de plus de 50 ans dans un
délai de deux semaines
cet objectif est réalisable car
actuellement 70 7% de cette tranche
d'âge est vacciné rousseau nu le vaccin
fighters green tech utilisé pour
vacciner la population serait efficace à
92 % si l'on se réfère à une étude menée
sur 163 me israélien selon l'organisme
d'assurance maladie maccabi pour
l'université américaine johns hopkins
le pays a enregistré plus de 650 mille
cas de kobe de 19 depuis le début de la
pandémie pour moins de 5000 morts